solid i would eat it but i'll let you
know my answer as we go through can't
date all three
i mean only one of them you could
hello my name is jenny and i am going to
try three different korean dishes cooked
by three different guys and choose who i
would want to go on a date with i'm a
korean american that has been incredibly
blessed with an amazing korean mother
who cooks all the time every day when we
go to restaurants it's like ugh mom's
food is way better so the bar is a
little bit high i want someone who
matches my energy because i can be very
high energy very low energy you're very
chaotic person
kind of
chaotic good hi i'm luke hi i'm justin
what's up i'm jen i came in smelled the
food everything smelled great so i feel
like we all made some pretty solid
dishes today
such a diplomatic answer i'm not hella
like competitive or anything but if i'm
gonna do something i'm gonna do a full
out right so i give everything my all
[Music]
i made jajangmyun and jumbo two classics
i feel like you know every koreans had
kind of chinese korean dishes i cooked
it a little earlier today it's a little
thick couldn't decide between the two so
i decided to go with both of them i even
peeled the shrimp for her that's real
love so
this is dumpling
smells like it should the noodles are
kind of um i don't know what in english
but it basically means like the noodles
are fat from soaking up all the liquid i
should uh mix it up a little it looks
pretty good these are some side dishes
let's see if they cut it up hmm
it looks cut up it looks good
looks like they also try to like arrange
the seafood in a slightly stylistic way
i don't know if that landed that's fair
but a for effort
do you know if they made this from
scratch i'll take that as a compliment
that's a compliment right or is it like
one of those packages you know like
pre-packaged they're kind of like fancy
ramen i can't tell she can't tell the
difference that's it that's a good thing
i know she's talking about but this is
from scratch but this is good aside from
the noodles bingo
i can't even pick them up i feel like
this says a plus effort
b plus foresight foresight okay
maybe this person's very diverse there's
a lot of diversity of seafood here i'm
just a complex guy i don't know like how
korean this person is because this is
not that spicy and i feel like korean
folks like really like their spice i i
didn't want to make it too spicy because
then that would just be like an
immediate no solid i would eat it but
i'll let you know my answer as we go
through you can't date all three
i mean only one of them you could
this guy made two things
oh she's excited
i like it
this is really good i feel like these
two dishes might have taken a lot of
effort so once again eight plus for
effort but the foresight oh there's
noodles down here too there's some
vegetables here maybe this person works
out i'll take it i'll take it how did
she know i'm just curious i wonder if
this person has like chinese influence
because it's like supposed to be like a
korean chinese fusion dish he's trying
to like translate that through food it
wasn't intentional but i'll take it but
this is so good i like this one just
it's the first one all right hold on
hold on hold on now hold on
[Music]
i mean
i guess honestly toku is such like a
home-cooked feeling like i never ordered
restaurants right i don't know just
reminds me of home like new year's and
stuff like that i spent a hell of a time
making the broth so i boiled the bones
and stuff for hella long and that's i
took put a lot of effort into it and
that's kind of like what i'm trying to
show right and then i'm gonna add in
keranjidan basically just like take a
thin sheet of egg yolk hopefully she
doesn't notice the egg whites got kind
of messed up a final touch yes so i have
the amazing machine
gotta have a sesame seed a little bit of
mandu good old homemade kimchi but yeah
it's not korean food without pancetta
first of all this is toku which is
basically rice cake soup i feel like
this person is very detail-oriented are
you yeah yeah yeah you can tell these
like little egg things are almost
perfectly chopped amazing that's kind of
hard to do also looks like there's like
cut up seaweed i don't know what's going
on here but i think it's an egg no i
knew you should call it out the extra
veggies on this side it looks like the
dumplings are slightly burnt though i
like mine crispy i think i'm good too
you wish i'm trying she's chewing that
for a minute she's still processing it
makes me think of my grandma it's
store-bought i fight it like an hour ago
you mean homemade
yeah homemade oh this dishware is a plus
because this is still really hot he
brought that himself
he brought it himself
foresight the thing that the other guy
didn't have
foresight foresight okay i feel like
between the two i like this one better
let me try this spinach thing
kind of tastes like you just put them in
water
how about gonna lie i pulled it out of
the container and i was like
it's just like so good because it's so
hot i should have got a stone pot kind
of reminds me of family you eat it in
the morning um you don't even eat it in
the evening i also feel like it's
seasoned really well the bone broth
let's go it was just good i feel like
this guy is like the most korean wait
she might she may be onto something
i feel like this guy maybe tries to take
on a little bit too much at a single
time hence the burnt dumplings that's
like actually a highly accurate
description of like yeah like that's
kind of crazy but like things turned out
okay so maybe this person is just like
used to taking on a lot in life like in
my life i just like i'm a time like i
don't say no to things so like i like i
overload my plate a lot i feel like this
person might be also very generous
there's like a hefty portion of food in
korean we say like to have a big hand
right it's plenty money like if you have
a big hand it means like when people
come over you give them a lot of food
once again it's it's really this pot
i've been waiting for an excuse to buy a
pot like this honestly let's move on for
the sake of moving on
the meat is also really tender and tasty
do you really like strawberries dude
i made busan a simple kind of braised
pork dish had a lot growing up so it
means a lot to me one thing to me that's
really important is like quality of
ingredients and i feel like with a
simpler dish like like bosam like
ingredients really show through getting
the sauce ready here the pork is all
plated and that's gonna be about it my
first impression of this man has an eye
for aesthetics because he didn't just
put the meat on the plate he put it on
this little lettuce thing the better
lettuce baby which like looks kind of
different from this lettuce thing so we
got two different lettuce types oh did
you really the variety yeah yeah let's
try this meat now so you get a little
bit of the meat you get a little bit of
the frosting
i appreciate that she put the whole
thing in her mouth she didn't take a
little bite this this human here he's a
little bit chill and she's just simple
very simple it's just the meat i don't
even know if this is seasoned meat when
i was little my mom and my grandma
they'd make kimchi like from scratch and
when you do that you typically have this
other meal after that using the
ingredients to make the kimchi and you
sort of have it with like this type of
meat this is also like a very communal
type of dish where like everyone eats it
together maybe this person has a lot of
friends i do love cooking for my friends
yeah like a simple family guy is what i
think i'm going to deem this person to
be
like they're kind of basic don't know if
they're like really that different from
each other maybe this person's a little
bit younger wow i am the youngest one
here but you're useless i feel like
whenever we have noodles it's always
like oh make sure they don't get soggy
like eat them before they get soggy and
you're told that as a
i feel like this person is just more
confident and secure and they're kind of
simple and this person like trusted you
too much but like kind of pulls it off
but kind of doesn't it kind of does it
but like there's nothing like super like
unique you know like there's no ba-bams
you know there's no risk we all went for
a pretty safe bed this is true
i feel like it's like this person and
then like equally these two folks look
at this it looks like a little ad from
one of those korean stores or
restaurants so i would say one three
three
not even two two about third place three
three eight congrats congratulations
wow
you said i take on too much which is
like kind of crazy that you said that
because that's like actually so real
like i have such a hard time like with
boundaries and saying no and stuff so um
but i'm also very much like
go full out if you're gonna do it so the
torso was the yeah
wait i feel like people are going to
think this was staged
i assure you it was not yeah yeah that
was real
i had no other ending in mind
so what so what's the deal like like we
went on a date or what like
well
you